[Música]
Oriente medio otra vez vuelve a estar en
Boca de todos y como si el tiempo no
avanzas otra vez Israel vuelve a ser el
epicentro del conflicto queridos amigos
amigas sí Israel vuelve a estar otra vez
en guerra Israel declara formalmente la
guerra jamás en su lucha por expulsar a
los militantes de su territorio una gran
movilización para acabar con un grupo
terrorista no es la primera vez que algo
así ocurre de hecho en 1982 y en 2006
Israel lanzó dos guerras contra el
Líbano para intentar acabar
respectivamente con la organización para
la liberación Palestina y con hezbolá
Pero y si os dijera que este breng genal
que se ha montado ahora podría llegar a
convertirse en toda una guerra abierta
entre varios países seguramente no os
pille por sorpresa al fin y al cabo no
sería la primera vez que sucede en
Oriente medio y desde luego tampoco
Israel en específico pero os hago una
pregunta qué país podría ser el primero
en declararle la guerra al Estado hebreo
pues muy seguramente el que ya está
llamando a la puerta el aviso de Irán a
la si Israel invade gaza
intervendría efectivamente mis queridos
amigos de visual politic Irán ya ha
enviado algunos avisos sobre una posible
guerra con Israel y esto no es moco de
Pao pensadlo bien Irán es una de las
tres potencias regionales de oriente
medio junto a la propia Israel y Arabia
saudí y cuenta con una capacidad militar
nada desdeñable sin embargo si bien Esto
supondría un fuerte soc a nivel inter
Nacional los analistas ya están
alertando de una posibilidad
especialmente inquietante amigos amigas
Si Irán llegara a entrar en guerra con
Israel Lo más seguro es que los Estados
Unidos se verían arrastrados al
conflicto y para muchos este sería el
preámbulo de un conflicto mucho pero que
muchísimo mayor y eso ha hecho que aquí
en visual politic nos hagamos unas
cuantas preguntas Cómo han sido las
relaciones entre Irán y los Estados
Unidos por qué le preocupa tanto a
Washington una posible intervención de
Irán en Israel llegaría realmente la
potencia norteamericana a atacar a la
república islámica Y aún más importante
tendría éxito hoy queridos amigos vamos
a responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes empecemos la historia por el
principio en caída
libre que Irán y Estados Unidos se
desprecian no es nada nuevo llevan
varias décadas odiándose el uno al otro
sin embargo no siempre fue así de hecho
Hubo un tiempo en el que fueron muy
buenos amigos no obstante como ya podéis
imaginar Todo cambió con la revolución
islámica de
1979 10 años después de que Irán se
independizara en
1943 Estados Unidos comenzó a acercarse
a Irán tras ayudar a un grupo de
militares iraníes a dar un golpe de
estado y derrocar al Primer Ministro
Mohamed mosab después de que este
nacionalizar la compañía de petróleos
angl persa desde aquel momento el sha
ret pahlavi tremendamente impopular
entre la población iraní pero Con un
fuerte apoyo del Tío Sam llegó al poder
Fue entonces cuando la amistad entre
Irán y Estados Unidos comenzó a florecer
por ejemplo en 1954 el sha concedió un
permiso de 25 años a empresas
petrolíferas estadounidenses para que
explotaran parte del petróleo
nacionalizado más tarde en
1957 ambos firmaron un acuerdo de
cooperación nuclear que se convirtió en
la base del programa nuclear de Irán y
que le permitió conseguir su primer
reactor nuclear en 1900 67 y no solo eso
en
1972 durante una visita del presidente
Richard Nixon al sha Estados Unidos
prometió permitir a Irán la compra de
sistemas de armas no nucleares si se
comprometía a proteger los intereses de
Estados Unidos frente a la unión
soviética en Oriente
medio no obstante llegó 1979 y la
revolución islámica dio un giro de 180
gr a esta bonita
amistad el ayatollah jomeini llegó al
poder Irán se convirtió en una República
islámica y Estados Unidos en su
principal enemigo junto a Israel desde
entonces su relación fue una cuesta
abajo y sin frenos por ejemplo Durante
los dos primeros años del régimen
islámico entre 1979 y 1981 Estados
Unidos tuvo que afrontar la crisis de
Los Rehenes americanos en Irán más tarde
Washington apoyó a Irak en la guerra que
saddam hussein desencadenó contra el
régimen de Irán entre 1980 y 1988 y
mientras tanto a Estados Unidos no le
tembló el pulso a la hora de imponer
duras sanciones contra Irán bueno en
2002 Poco después de los ataques
terroristas al World train Center en
Nueva York el expresidente George Bush
incluyó a Irán junto a irq y Corea del
Norte en lo que denominó el eje del
mal de mal en peor sin embargo hubo un
momento de calma en toda esta tensión en
2015 10 años después de que se
descubriera el programa nuclear
clandestino de Irán Estados Unidos la
República islámica y y otros países
europeos firmaron el famoso plan de
acción integral conjunto un plan que
limitaba la capacidad nuclear que Irán
podía desarrollar y la sometía a una
estricta vigilancia un plan que pocos
años después se fue al traste así que ya
lo veis en general la relación entre
Estados Unidos e Irán durante las
últimas cuatro décadas ha estado plagada
de tensión Y sí es cierto se han dado
algún respiro temporal Pero la realidad
es que las hostilidades nunca han cesado
del todo y de hecho estos años no han
hecho más que empeorar
fijaos
un cúmulo de
problemas seguramente fueron muchos los
que pensaron allá por el 2018 que bueno
Irán y Estados Unidos al menos habían
entrado en un espacio de calma con el
plan de acción integral conjunto sin
embargo si algo nos ha dejado claro el
mundo durante todos estos años es que no
podemos dar nada por sentado y Justo eso
fue lo que sucedió con aquella aparente
calma entre Estados Unidos e Irán que
acabó saltando por los aires Trump
abandona el acuerdo nuclear con Irán que
tanto despreció efectivamente Trump
abandonó el programa que había puesto
algo de paz entre Washington y Terán el
expresidente no iba a tolerar más
amenazas vacías del régimen islamista
según el mismo dijo Así que no tardó en
imponer nuevas y durísimas sanciones
contra el régimen de los ayatolás
esperando que así Irán parara su
programa nuclear sin embargo adivináis
lo que hizo Irán desde ese preciso
momento efectivamente dejar de cumplir
el acuerdo por
completo
el país de los ayatolás intensificó el
enriquecimiento de uranio hasta tal
punto de que en 2019 la agencia
Internacional de la energía atómica
alertó de que mucho ojo K Iran ya había
conseguido un enriquecimiento del 84
por. para que os hagáis una idea una
arma nuclear necesita de un uranio
enriquecido al 90 es decir que en 2019
ya estaban a punto de conseguirlo y
precisamente por eso empezaron a saltar
un montón de Voces dando la alarma ya no
tenemos la distancia de seguridad de un
año de ruptura para llegar a la energía
nuclear Irán está a 12 semanas de la
ruptura a un paso de llegar al 90 por de
uranio enriquecido cantidad suficiente
para una bomba para transformar la bomba
en un arma y completar su adaptación a
una ojiva para un misil se necesitan
unos dos años más frente a esto la
administración biden que intentó retomar
las negociaciones con Irán sobre el
acuerdo nuclear ha continuado con las
sanciones contra el régimen iraní
esperando intentando aislarlo aún más
internacionalmente sin embargo el
resultado no ha sido hoy por hoy del
todo Bueno de hecho acción ha acabado
reforzando amistades que Estados Unidos
prefiere debilitar Como por ejemplo la
amistad de Irán con
Rusia y es que veréis aunque Terán
hubiera preferido estrechar lazos con
china las sanciones internacionales han
resultado un incómodo obstáculo para sus
relaciones con el gigante asiático ya
que lógicamente china pues no quiere
arriesgarse a perder el enorme comercio
que comparte con los países de occidente
por esa razón Irán ha optado sobre todo
por reforzar sus vínculos con Rusia otro
estado Pari internacional azotado
también por un montón de sanciones en un
principio la cooperación entre estos dos
países fue fundamentalmente materia
energética sin embargo la guerra de
Rusia con Ucrania ha hecho que esta
cooperación haya saltado a otros Campos
digamos más estratégicos fijaos Guerra
de Ucrania Estados Unidos dice que Irán
es ahora el principal apoyo militar de
Rusia amigos desde el comienzo de la
invasión rusa Ucrania Irán ha sido capaz
de enviar según Fuentes del propio
gobierno ucraniano cerca de 2400 drones
a Rusia hablamos en este caso de drones
cicac modelo sahb 131 y 136 drones que
ayudan enormemente a los esfuerzos rusos
en Ucrania especialmente por su relación
calidad precio y es que veréis tenemos
que tener en cuenta que mientras la
producción de cada uno de estos drones
cuesta en torno a los $2,000 derribarlos
le cuesta a Ucrania de media entre
14,000 y 15,000 por eso ambos países se
han comprometido ahora a construir una
fábrica de estos drones dentro de la
propia Rusia Pero vale está bien Irán le
está siendo muy útil a Rusia Pero qué sa
caerán de su acercamiento a Moscú Pues
bien Creo que podemos decir que este
movimiento del régimen iraní es más bien
una inversión a largo plazo en la
potencia rusa sí es cierto Irán va a
recibir cazas avanzados helicópteros y
sistemas de defensa antiaéreos incluso
está interesado en aprender a esquivar
las sanciones occidentales tal y como lo
ha hecho Rusia y tal y como ya os hemos
contado aquí en visual politic pero
sobre todo Irán Busca en Rusia
protección en las organizaciones
internacionales y más particularmente
protección frente a los Estados Unidos y
la Unión
Europea
con todo dadas las circunstancias es
probable que la mayor preocupación del
gobierno estadounidense no sea ni el
programa nuclear de Irán ni tampoco su
amistad con Rusia sino los aliados con
los que cuenta este país en la región Y
es que veréis cuando Irán quiere atacar
un país no lo hace directamente sino a
través de grupos terroristas a los que
financia intensamente el mejor ejemplo
de estos es precisamente hezbola hezbola
un grupo del que ya os hemos hablado en
este canal Es un grupo terrorista y un
partido político libanés que nació
durante la Guerra Civil del país entre
1975 y 1990 este grupo amigos recibe
tanto un montón de equipamiento militar
y cientos y cientos de misiles como
cientos de millones de dólares cada año
desde Irán de esta forma hezbola se ha
convertido en el Aliado más importante
de Terán en todo Oriente medio ya que
controla casi todos los aspectos del
Líbano un país fronterizo con Israel y
de hecho esta organización ya ha tenido
un montón de rif y rafes con el estado
hebreo en los últimos tiempos incluyendo
en las últimas semanas la frontera norte
se calienta con nuevos disparos de
cohetes y ataques de hezbolá
contrapuestos de las fuerzas de defensa
de Israel Por el momento hezbolá no se
ha atrevido a atacar Israel a gran
escala ni tampoco a declararle la Guerra
sin embargo el protagonista del nuevo
conflicto con el estado hebreo esto es
jamás también tiene fuertes vínculos con
Irán Es cierto que Irán no es tan
cercano a jamás como lo es con hezbolá
pero un así su cooperación se remonta a
los años 90 momento en el que la
República islámica comenzó a financiar
al grupo terrorista palestino con más de
50 millones de dólares cada año y un
montón de armas que ha estado enviando a
través de hezbola de hecho en 2012 por
ejemplo jamás ya ha llegó a bombardear
Tel viip con misiles iraníes de largo
alcance fajar 5 de hecho y tal y como os
hemos contado aquí en visual politic en
estos momento son muchos los que creen
que irá ha estado detrás del ataque
terrorista de jamás contra Israel del
pasado 7 de octubre Pero qué pasaría si
realmente Se confirma que Irán estuvo
detrás del atentado a Israel y aún más
importante podría Estados Unidos dar el
paso entonces e intervenir militarmente
contra Irán Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
Irán próximo objetivo
americano ya os hemos contado que hay
ciertas voces que sospechan que Irán
estuvo detrás de los atentados contra
Israel a principios del mes de octubre
el gobierno de Israel también lo cree
firmemente y la verdad es que todo
apunta que fue así sin embargo desde
Washington afirman que bueno que todavía
no hay pruebas sólidas que confirmen la
participación iraní en el atentado
terrorista de jamás pero
independientemente de si Irán tuvo algo
que ver o no lo que sí ha dejado claro
es que de continuar la respuesta israelí
contra jamás en gaza no dudarán en
intervenir y comenzar un conflicto
abierto contra Israel para muchos esto
llevaría a que Estados Unidos se uniera
al conflicto en favor de Israel
directamente Pero por qué Qué
importancia tiene Israel para Estados
Unidos pues veréis además de ser uno de
sus mejores aliados Israel ha tenido una
importancia estratégica crucial para los
Estados Unidos desde el año 1967 en la
Guerra Fría le sirvió como una especie
de dique de mantención de base avanzada
frente a la influencia soviética en
Oriente medio y hoy en cierto modo lo es
frente al radicalismo islámico y a las
potencias que pretenden socavar los
intereses del Tío Sam por su lado Israel
comparte con Estados Unidos su
experiencia su información de
inteligencia Y llegado el caso todo un
ejército preparado para cualquier
contingencia por eso la cooperación
entre estos dos países a nivel militar
económico y tecnológico ha sido tan
intensa Así que Hay pocas dudas de que
si Irán atacar a Israel Estados Unidos
intervendría directamente en el
conflicto Aunque eso sí en estos últimos
años cuando Israel ha chocado contra
Irán la respuesta ha sido directamente
israelí y ha sido contundente Israel
lanza un ataque militar masivo contra
objetivos iraníes en Siria no obstante
amigos actualmente la preocupación
norteamericana por un ataque iraní sobre
Israel va más allá de un posible ataque
con misiles ahora mismo hay otro factor
totalmente determinante que tiene en
vilo a los Estados Unidos y a todo
Oriente medio aquí Hablamos de una
posible Irán
nuclear Y es que veréis si bien es
cierto que los os indican que Irán puede
tener ya en su posesión suficiente
uranio enriquecido al 90 por estos
aseguran que aún tardaría entre 6 y 24
meses para poder desarrollar un arma
nuclear no obstante Y aunque la
inteligencia de Estados Unidos asegure
que Irán no reabrió su programa de
desarrollo de armas nucleares en 2022 la
realidad es que no podemos estar del
todo seguros en cuanto así Irán cuenta
ya con algún arma nuclear o no hay que
tener en cuenta que de desde que Estados
Unidos se retiró del plan de acción
integral conjunto en 2018 la
transparencia iraní en materia nuclear
ha sido casi nula y no solo eso también
debemos tener en mente que el ensamblaje
de un arma nuclear puede hacerse
perfectamente bajo tierra haciendo con
ello inútiles los análisis por
satélite evidentemente y como podéis
imaginar Israel tiene especial temor a
esta situación que podría significar con
mucha diferencia la principal amenaza
existencial sobre el De hecho por eso
mismo el Primer Ministro israelí
netanyahu ya declaró Esto hace tan solo
unos meses cómo se impide que una nación
canaya adquiera armas nucleares tuvieron
una que se llama el iraq de saddam
hussein fue detenido por la fuerza
militar la nuestra hubo otra llamada
Siria que intentó desarrollar armas
nucleares y fue detenido por una acción
militar la nuestra este escenario tan
sumamente hostil con una Irán que
potencialmente podría llegar a atacar
Israel con armamento nuclear es algo que
tiene de los nervios a mucha gente en
Washington y lo cierto es que el tema
con Irán se está poniendo Al rojo vivo
el apresamiento de petroleros su apoyo a
Rusia su participación en el ataque de
Israel y la posible bomba nuclear todos
ellos son motivos de sobra para que la
cosa pase a mayores muchos analistas ya
plantean la posibilidad de que Estados
Unidos intervenga si la violencia escala
en la región pero podría ser la
intervención de Estados Unidos en Irán
exitosa Pues de momento la
administración biden Ya ha decidido ir
preparándose para un posible conflicto
Estados Unidos enviará su segundo
portaaviones al mediterráneo Oriental el
uss eschenauer se unirá al uss Ford
frente a Israel en caso de que Estados
Unidos quisiera efectivamente atacar a
Irán lo más probable es que necesitara
mucho más que simplemente dos
portaaviones pero claro en la región ya
hay mucho equipo norteamericano
incluyendo una enorme base aérea en la
misma Qatar Y es que debemos tener en
mente que Irán cuenta con los mayores
arsenales tanto de misiles balísticos
del aro alcance como de drones de todo
Oriente medio su ejército está entre los
20 más poderosos de todo el mundo su
imparando incluso algunas de las
métricas de Israel sin embargo amigos
Estados Unidos sigue siendo con mucha
diferencia la primera potencia militar
del
[Música]
mundo si sois fieles seguidores de
visual politics sabéis que aunque no
esté en su mejor momento el ejército del
Tío Sam sigue siendo prácticamente
imbatible por eso no es una locura que
podría fácilmente destruir instalaciones
claves de Irán Como por ejemplo las
bases de producción de armas y drones o
las de enriquecimiento de uranio sin
embargo Estados Unidos tendría que tener
mucho cuidado porque amigos hay una muy
alta posibilidad de que los costes de su
posible intervención superaran con
creces a los beneficios y os
preguntaréis Por qué pues veréis si
Estados Unidos interviniera tanto Irán
como sus aliados no dudarían en atacar
de manera rápida y directa tanto en las
bases americanas de la región como en la
propia Israel pero no solo eso también
se correría el riesgo de que Irán
cerrara por completo el estrecho de
ormuz causando probablemente con ello
otra grave crisis energética y económica
a nivel
mundial así que ya lo veis las
relaciones entre Irán y Estados Unidos
llevan siendo hostiles más más de 40
años y justo en estos últimos han ido
incluso peor el fortalecimiento del
programa nuclear iraní el apoyo a Rusia
en Ucrania y ahora La amenaza de atacar
Israel han hundido en lo más profundo la
relación entre ambos los analistas ya
están planteando la posibilidad de que
Estados Unidos llegue a intervenir en
Irán llegado el caso tiene la fuerza
militar y el apoyo de Israel en Oriente
medio pero siendo honestos no sería cosé
ni cantar de momento el conflicto entre
Israel y jamás parece estar en sus
primeras etapas solo el tiempo nos dirá
si Irán acaba cumpliendo su amenaza Y si
hay respuesta de los Estados Unidos así
que Mientras tanto ahora el turno es
para todos vosotros podría Estados
Unidos atacar con éxito a Irán sería
capaz de regar con dinero a Israel a la
par que a Ucrania afectará esto también
al desenlace del conflicto ucraniano
Pues como siempre podéis dejarme
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios
no olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos toda la semanas
así que suscribiros a este canal y dle a
la campanita para No perderos ninguno de
los siguientes si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto